hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play catlateral
damage now after the week that I've had
in a stressful amount of work that I put
on my voice I decided that it was time
to kick back and relax and discover what
it truly means to be a cat let's get to
it
now as you can see I start out as a
pretty little kitty trying to make his
way around the room swiping things with
my pretty little kitty haha wouldn't you
know it when they follow the floor I get
points now it may not seem like I have a
lot of points right now but just you
wait as I start racking up the combos
with my little kitty skills you're gonna
see that point meter climb up into the
thousands what do we have here this
little kitty spies a Betty Betty bubble
book a ship itty bitty baby - baby -
boom pow look at those points rack up
doesn't seem so hard to get to a hundred
thousand now does it I didn't think so
Oh would you look at all these
delightful delicious things for me to
throw on the floor just willy-nilly like
there wasn't a care in the world it just
makes you realize that there's more to
life than chasing your tail like a dog
when you can just get on the counter
more stuff a shivudu bibbity bibbity
baby bye-bye mr. robot man how I liked
playing with you then in the future you
might realize if there is other things
here higher in life if you just climb on
your little kitty kind feet the door off
and see what the world is really like
from another perspective oh yeah let's
get this out of here so I can leap like
a kitty cat and swipe these big toys
down oh yeah getting close to that
hundred thousand now but I'm running out
of time so I'll just finish this off
with that epic final common joy that was
it good for you it was good for me cuz
we won this little shindig and now we
know this stupid octopus this doesn't
know what he's doing and Bo never
cooperate with you have a good one